[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله معكم محمد امزيم
نستعرض معا ابرز اخبار الاسبوع الماضي
بايجاز وضمننا ابرز الاحداث فيضانات ليبيا
تخلف الاف القتل والمفقودين اعنفوا زلزال
يضربوا المغرب منذ قرن زياره زعيم كوريا
الشماليه الى روسيا نبدا اخبارنا من ليبيا
التي عاشت مدنها الشرقيه الاسبوع الماضي
تحت وطاهه كارثه الانسانيه بسبب فيضانات
وصفت بالاسوا في القرن الحادي والعشرين
جراء اعصار دانيال حيث غمرت السيول قرى
باكملها واسفرت عن مصرعي وفقدان الالاف
ودمار هائل في المنازل والسدود في حين
ناشدت السلطات تقديم دعم دولي لجهود
الانقاذ وحضرت من انتشار الاوبئه بسبب
التكدس
دعوني اتوجه لزميل لصهيب العصا الذي يعكف
على تغطيه هذا الملف يا مرحبا
صهيب ما الذي
جعل تداعيات اعصار دانيال في درنه ماساويه
لهذه الدرجات اكثر من سبب ممكن نحصرها في
سبعين رئيسين السبب الاول هو الجغرافيا
نتحدث عن مدينه تقع على طرفي شق صخري كبير
يمتد الى حوالي 60 الى 70 كيلومتر هذا
الشق الصخري وادي درنا وهذا السبب مهم
للغايه لانه اندفاع المياه في هذا الوادي
ادى الى فيضان هذه المياه بشكل كبير على
كل احياء المدينه تقريبا هذا سبب الجغرافي
السبب الثاني هو سبب السدود هناك سدان
رئيسيان سد الكبير الذي يبعد حوالي 15
كيلو مترا عن وسط مدينه درنه وسد الاخر هو
القريب من الشاطئ انفجار او انهيار السد
الكبير ادى الى تدفق المياه بشكل كبير هذا
السد وفق التقارير حتى الان تقول انه لم
تتم هناك عمليات صيانه لهذا السد ولم تتم
تصريف المياه وايضا هناك اتهامات بالتقصير
والقصور في تلك المنطقه من جهه الجهات
المسؤوله في صيانه هذا السبت نتحدث عن سبب
جغرافي طبيعي وسبب اخر بيد الانسان هو سبب
السدود المتهالكه والتي لم تجرى لها
عمليات صيانه منذ عام 2011 وبالتالي هذا
الامر ادى الى تدفق هذا الاعداد الكبيره
من الضحايا في مدينه درعا شكرا جزيلا يا
صهيب يعطيك الف عافيه نترككم بالتاكيد
تواصل هذه التقارير والتغطيه مع زملاء في
شاشه الجزيره الان نتوجه الى عين المكان
الى درنا تحديدا حيث هو مراسل للجزيره
محمد البقالي
يا مرحبا محمد محمد وصلت الى درنا ضمن
فريقنا من الجزيره قل لنا مشاهداتك هناك
نعم محمد الواقع ان مدينه دارنه هي منطقه
وليس في هذا الوصف اي مبالغه احد السكان
الذين تحدثوا اليهم قال انه يحس كما لو ان
مدينته قصفت بقنبله ذريه قد يبدو في ذلك
نوع من المبالغه ولكن عندما ترى حجم
الدمار الذي لحق بالمدينه الاحياء التي
اقتلعت وستت بكاملها الالاف القتلى
والاف المفقودين وعندما تشتمه الرائحه
التي ما زالت تنبعث من تحتها الرخام رائحه
الجثث المتحلله تحس فعلا بان المدينه
منكوبه بالكامل وانها ربما تعيش اسوا وليس
ربما هذا يقينا تعيش اسوء كارثه في
تاريخها شكرا يعطيك الصحه محمد البقالي
[موسيقى]
من ليبيا الى المغرب الذي يعيش كارثه
انسانيه هو الاخر حيث باغت سكانه الجمعه
الماضيه زلزال هو الاعنف منذ قرن واسهر عن
مقتل نحو ثلاثه الاف شخص بينما تجاوز عدد
المصابين خمسه الاف والحق الزلزال واضرارا
جسيمه بمعالم تاريخيه الهبه الشعبيه لجمع
المساعدات للمنكوبين كانت من المشاهد
اللافته في عقب الزلزال فقد شهدت حملات
التبرع بالدم للمصابين اقبالا واسعا من
المغاربه وسارع مواطنون لشراء المواد
الغذائيه والاساسيه للتبرع بها للمتضررين
كما تمكن خبراء مغاربه من توفير الطاقه
والانترنت بالمجان في المناطق المنكوبه
الالاف اذا باتوا في العراء بعد تهدم
بيوتهم جزئيا او كليا ولكن كيف هي اوضاع
الاهالي بعد اسبوع من وقوع الزلزال دعونا
نتوجه الى مراسله الجزيره عمر الحاج في
امزميز باقليم الحوز يا مرحبا عمر
المشهد عندك نعم محمد ثمانيه ايام مرت على
الزلزال والحقيقه الجهود ما تزال مكثفه
بعد تغير مثبت ايام حتى الان تغيرت حياه
الكثير من الناس فقدوا الكثير من احبائهم
وفقدوا الكثير من دورهم وايضا تغير نمط
الاستجابه
سواء المساعدات المدنيه او حتى مساعدات
التي تقوم بها فرق الانقاذ المختصه قبل
قليل تحدثنا الى احد المسؤولين في الوقايه
الوطنيه المغربيه وقال ان ليس عندهم لم
يقروا حتى الان سقفا زمنيا العمل مستمر
حتى اشعار اخر او حتى
يتوقف تنقطع الفرص عنك انقاذ الاخرين كما
تشاهدون القرن المركوبه في الجبال خلفي
الصعوبات لا تكمل فقط في وعوره الطرق او
انقطاعها وانهيارات صخريه بل انها حتى
المروحيات التي تحاول الوصول لفرق لانقاذ
الى تلك المناطق تواجه صعوبه وتعود واضطره
نتيجه الرياح العكسيه للعوده مره اخرى الى
الى مخيمات التنسيق يعطيك العافيه عمر تحت
عنوان الفضاء المغلق تحقيق جديد لبرنامج
الجزيره ما خفي اعظم كشف عن تعاون وثيق
بين جهاز الشباكه الاسرائيلي
لحذف المحتوى المناهض لاسرائيل على منصتي
فيسبوك وانستجرام فضلا عن استهداف الشركه
للمحتوى العربي والفلسطيني وبعد 24 ساعه
من بث التحقيق حدث فيسبوك حساب مقدم
البرنامج تامر المسحال قبل ان يعاود فتحه
دون تقديم اي اسباب وتنديدا بسياسات
الشركه الامريكيه تجاه المحتوى الفلسطيني
اطلق الناشطون واسما بعنوان ميته تحجب
فلسطين لنلقي نظره على ابرز التفاعلات على
هذا الوسم سام قال هذه حريه التعبير عند
الغربيين يجب ان تفهم الشع العربيه ان
الغربه لا يؤمن بحريه التعبير بل يوظفها
خدمه لمصالحه اما حمزه الفايدي فاكد ان
الخلاصه انهم يتعاملون معنا على اننا
مستهلكون نستهلك سلعهم وهم قد استهلكون
احتلالا ولا يحق لنا ان نعبر عن حقنا من
خلال منابرهم فهذه هي المنابر مثل ما يقول
جعلت لضياع حقوقنا وتدمير قيمها في اول
زياره خارجيه له منذ جائحه كورونا زعيم
كوريا الشماليه اون التقى الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين في روسيا وقد عقد الرئيسان
قمه في قاعده
الموقع ومحادثات رسميه محورت حول تعزيز
العلاقات بين البلدين خصوصا على الصعيد
العسكري في وقت تحضر فيه واشنطن من اتفاق
محتمل بين الجانبين بشان صفقه اسلحه لدعم
روسيا في حربها على اوكرانيا القطار الذي
استقله الى روسيا لفت انظار العالم
فالقلعه المتحركه كما يسمى لا تتجاوز
سرعته 60 كيلومترا في الساعه لان كم يفضله
عن الطائرات الرئاسيه اذا اردتم معرفه
المزيد عن مزايا القطار شاهدوا الفيديو في
التعليقات ننتقل الان الى حدث ينتظره عشاق
التكنولوجيا سنويا وهو مؤتمر شركه ابل
الذي كشفت فيه النقاب عن احدث منتجاتها
وهي اربعه هواتف جديده وساعتان ذكيتان ومن
ابرز المزايا في النسخ الجديده من الهواتف
زياده اداء المعالج ودقه الكاميرا
واستبدال منفذ الشحن لتخضع بذلك الشركه
للضغوط الاوروبيه التي طلبتها بالتحول الى
منفذ يو اس بي سي وستتوفر الهواتف في
الاسواق بنهايه سبتمبر الجاري اذا مزايا
جديده والاسعار ذاتها ولكن برايكم هل
يستحق هاتف ايفون الجديد الشراء فعلا
اجبون في التعليقات نلتقي بحول الله
الاسبوع المقبل مع ايجاز اسبوعي جديدا
كنتم طابت اوقاتكم بكل خير
[موسيقى]